in this short overview I will discuss
App Engine tell you what it is and how
it helps you build applications at cloud
scale I'm Laurence Moroney and I'm a
developer advocate in Google working on
the Google cloud platform App Engine is
an integral part of the Google cloud
platform
this family of technologies can provide
you with everything you need to build
for the cloud including platform and
infrastructure as a service as well as
Big Data cloud storage and much more
cloud applications should be able to
scale at a moment's notice to handle
huge or tiny amounts of traffic
you should only pay for the
infrastructure capacity your
applications actually use when using App
Engine you can build your applications
to run on top of Google's world-class
infrastructure you don't have to worry
about provisioning and managing a data
center that scales to meet your demand
Google takes care of all of that and you
can just focus on building the best
possible app for your users when
developing for App Engine you can use
popular languages such as Python Java
PHP and go as well as existing
frameworks like Django and flask you can
focus on your code and let Google worry
about database administration server
configuration sharding load balancing
and everything else that you need to
build at scale you have multiple options
for storing your data including
relational databases scalable file
storage and a lightweight data store App
Engine makes you more productive by
reducing the need to write boilerplate
code manage services such as task queues
memcache and the users API we'll help
you build world-class applications you
can use the tools you know including
Eclipse IntelliJ maven get and much more
the App Engine SDK allows you to test
applications locally in a simulated
environment and then deploy your app
with simple to use tools some of the
world's most popular web services are
built on our platform you can scale up
to billions of requests per day and
scale down with traffic subsides there's
lots of great stuff available to you as
a developer and you can learn more about
using them at this URL
developers.google.com slash App Engine
the cloud is one of the most important
advances in computer technology in
decades App Engine is built on the same
infrastructure that allows Google to
return billions of search results in
Millicent
serve over six billion hours of YouTube
video per month and provide storage for
425 million Gmail users and this scales
to your demand with free SDKs it's easy
to get started and you can be up and
running with building cloud applications
very quickly companies such as snapchat
Rovio the makers of Angry Birds and Khan
Academy already run an app engine giving
their customers scalable reliable
service with App Engine this
infrastructure is available to you and
you'll only have to pay for what you use
you can learn more about App Engine at
these URLs cloud.google.com slash
product slash App Engine developers
google.com slash App Engine and there's
some terrific samples to get you started
at Google cloud platform github al thank
you and welcome to the cloud